is the Brandon German movie that he's in
the movie I was supposed to do right
yeah they replaced you last minute oh
were you gonna be the DJ
I thought it was like driving these two
girls somewhere oh I think Kyle my buddy
Kyle the director knewichek he might
have swooped your role that he did yeah
and the reason why I got replaced was
because of kovid yeah the the I'm
totally fine is the movie we're talking
about yeah and it was shot like height
of of uh covid yeah so it was really
small crew yeah I think it was like six
people yeah I remember him calling me
that night he's like dude I think one of
the actresses got covered or something
and he was just like I just can't you
know risk you coming out here yeah and I
go
I cried you did I could shed a tear yeah
because it's my dream to be in that
movie well maybe a sequel it could have
a sequel it will maybe he's a great guy
is he not Kyle or Brandon which one
[Laughter]
where did these Mind Games what's up man
are you still mad about at the diner
yeah and I'm finding a way to get you
yeah I know but I'm just saying I
already apologized to you man if you're
gonna do this but you have to accept
that I'm pressing on your downfall
I thought it was covered that didn't you
get you in the movie oh
right now because I didn't get a missed
call from him oh yeah call him right now
I need to talk to her because I think
it's him you know what this is great and
you know I mean all those things I think
about you know I mean that are happening
they really do happen in my mind yeah in
real life hey dermer
give me give it to me Bobby is having a
crisis got replaced intentionally on the
movie okay good to me
bro don't tell him put in the mic
what up
hey how's it going
he's coming unhinged I'm not picking me
I got banned from hinge you did you
opened my Apple page hey um bro so Blake
was telling me that the reason why you
replaced me in the movie wasn't because
of somebody getting covered it was
because Blake sat you down and said I
don't want to work with him
what no yeah no no that's what it is
yes that's what I believe Blake over you
and you know what's so funny Let me say
something to you this last weekend the
UF a guy came up to me at the store and
The Exchange number his name is McCone
yes right McComb right and he goes I'm
president Thurman so I was so generous
with them I sat down with him and I go
you know I mean what do you let's do
something together let's come up with
some ideas isn't that because he's a
creative guy right but I did that
because you know partly you know I know
you right yeah and I want you to look
good
right right and this is how you treat me
with this guy
with this guy you know how macone I
started mentoring him he reached out to
me right
your type and that's how I
met I don't know what you're doing right
now but um that's a really good segue to
somewhere else
talk about Blake okay yeah he's not here
one of our cast who came to set their
sister drove him to set tested positive
I called you in 2020. I was like look
here's the scenario we're scared to
break the bubble and you were like dude
say less I'm scared I don't even want to
leave the house
I said that
I said that it's your decision yeah you
were
[Laughter]
okay my bad yeah you didn't want to show
up dude wow
show up for me and like the love sense
but the pressure and and the situation
of covid you were you were scared as
were we and then when I was like look we
might have a positive we're scared to
break the bubble
uh okay you know what let's put this
behind us yeah I don't know yeah yeah
whatever I don't know whatever I don't
know it's just not adding up
all right I'll talk to you later bye
yeah it's not adding a business yeah
yeah that doesn't make any sense no it
doesn't yeah yeah so when you sat down
with dermer what exactly did you say
um I just said like you know you were
addicted me back in the day
all right so you let me ask you
something this let me ask you this then
so you who who do you think is a better
guy a better guy yeah I'm gonna give you
two options me or what's the the